in this video I want Akbar registery
mitochondrial diseases so mitochondria
have their own circular DNA which is
mitochondrial DNA represented mtDNA and
it's located in the matrix of the
mitochondria and this DNA is separate
from the cell's nuclear DNA okay and
mutations in the mitochondrial DNA
interrupt normal mitochondrial functions
especially oxidative phosphorylation
which of course we're talking about
electron transport chain and ATP
production and that's really bad for
tissues that make and use lots of ATP
two key examples are nervous tissue and
muscle tissue and that's actually pretty
important we'll talk more about that
momentarily okay now most mitochondrial
diseases are caused by mitochondrial DNA
mutations and mitochondrial DNA actually
has a higher mutation rate than the
cells nuclear DNA and also a really
important thing to know about
mitochondrial diseases diseases is that
they exhibit maternal inheritance okay
what does that mean well that means that
if the mother has it then all of her
children will have it okay so pedigrees
look something like this so if we have
an affected female here then you'll
notice that every single one of her
children is going to have it now
affected males do not pass on the the
disease but affected females pass it on
to all of their children okay so so why
is this why do i deconned riyo diseases
exhibit maternal inheritance okay well
it's because all the mitochondria in a
zygote comes from the ovum which of
course is
is coming that egg is coming from the
mother sperm mitochondria which of
course come from the father or sperm
sperm which is from the father the
mitochondria in sperm are in the
flagellum or the tail of the sperm which
actually falls off during or upon
fertilization so the sperm don't
contribute the mitochondria they only
contribute the nucleus to the zygote no
mitochondria okay so and of course all
children are all they start off as a
zygote and they get their mitochondria
entirely from their mother so if that
mitochondria is is mutated then all of
the children are going to have that
mutated mitochondria okay whereas the
father because the mitochondria don't
actually end up in the in this I go they
don't the fathers cannot pass on
mitochondrial diseases
okay so examples to nowhere be familiar
with first one here is the most common
hereditary mitochondrial disease is
lepers hereditary optic neuropathy so or
LH o n okay and this is a defect in
complex one electron transport chain or
nadh dehydrogenase and key features are
progressive the really the key feature
is progressive painless bilateral loss
of central vision that's pretty
important okay that's like the key thing
and it usually starts in one eye and the
other eye follows a few weeks or a few
months later and the usual onset is in
the third decade of life which would be
in their tune in individuals 20s right
because 0 through 10 is the first decade
11 through 20 second decade 20 to 30 21
to 30 is the third decade this is due to
optic nerve damage okay
nerve damage and it starts with central
blurriness or cloudiness and in it and
it can worsen but the peripheral vision
can remain intact
and this tends to affect males more than
females now sometimes we have a
situation called allege o n plus which
would include peripheral neuropathy as
well as nonspecific myopathy often
associated with just muscle weakness but
I mentioned just a moment ago that a
nervous tissue and muscle tissue use a
lot making use a lot of ATP so when the
mitochondria is messed up then it ATP
production is not going to be where it
needs to be and so the tissue that would
suffer most from that are the ones that
depend heavily on ATP and I would
include nervous and muscle tissue and in
the case of LH o n we've got a situation
of nerve damage right is just the key
situation here optic nerve damage
specifically that causes that causes
this disease ok so just pay attention to
all the examples you're going to see a
lot of the key features associated with
damaged nervous and muscle tissue ok
cool so next go to the next one
you